you know I've talked to you in private
about this but this would be ism in
regard to comedians in cars getting
coffee the the I thought that you more
than anyone got stuff out of Eddie
Murphy he had a respect for you because
you're from Long Island he's from Long
Island and you guys worked in some of
the clubs when he was starting out and
you were starting out at the same time
yes together yeah we work together many
nice do you think that's why he gave you
the interview because he respects you
well all comedians on some level respect
each other because we're all doing the
same thing I think he knows I'm not
interested in anything about him
personally really I was like talking
silly you know and he likes it and so
that's that's what that show was about
this is the silly way that comedians
talked to each other it was like a real
bonding session it really was my
favorite thing was him explaining how
much he was obsessed with Planet of the
Apes that's the kind of thing I love to
find out about people that's right he
went to go ape for a day they played a
movie it's in order and he went through
the whole thing who's there for ten
hours of the theater go eight for a day
it was close that's why that's why I
love the interview because I've never
seen him so animated but here's the
question and I want a truthful answer I
really need to know this sure when you
were there and Eddie Murphy was starting
out you have the kind of mentality where
I think you remember people sets I think
you remember where they were doing Eddie
was not so fully realized right you saw
the development of course of course
everybody develops you don't you start
out as a genius Eddie you know do you
think anybody thought that TV series
that I did was gonna come out of me
nobody thought that I didn't think that
right you know you just get when Eddie
got on in front of that camera there was
a magical some people have a magical
relationship with that lens he does that
glass something about it it's it's shiny
it's sparkly
he he just he lights up when that when
that camera comes up right
you